[Musique]
nous
on
sous le directoire sous le consulat à la
fin de l' empire pendant la restauration
il a attendu ce trône pendant presque
quarante ans
[Musique]
mais
le roi louis philippe 1er vécu la
période la plus passionnante de
l'histoire de france
il connut les jours tumultueux de la
révolution française les horreurs de la
terreur l'ascension puis la chute de
l'empiré napoléonien et la restauration
des bourbons qui lui succéda la
providence le destine à à des postes de
haute responsabilité
quand il fut très jeune et extrêmement
vieux au début sa place dans la famille
royale et son engouement pour les idées
libérales rendirent populaire ce jeune
homme qui accédaient à l'âge adulte dans
une france en pleine révolution
mais le climat politique allait bientôt
prendre un tour nouveau
considéré comme une menace d'abord par
les révolutionnaires radicaux qui
désiraient renversé louis saez et
marie-antoinette puis par les régimes
qui suivirent
ce prince intelligent et progressistes
se vit forcé de rester en marge de la
société pendant des décennies
c'est ainsi que louis philippe passe à
une grande partie de sa vie a observé le
cours des choses et à attendre le moment
où ils pourraient de nouveau occuper une
place de premier plan
simplement parce qu'il fait partie de la
famille la famille royale de france est
le descendant direct du frère de louis
xiv de monsieur et à travers les
générations
ses ascendants ses ancêtres se sont
mariés à plusieurs reprises avec
également des descendants de louis xiv
il apparaît comme une solution idéale
entre une royauté incarné de manière un
petit peu trop strictes au goût de
certains par charge de 10 et une
monarchie plus libérale type monarchie
anglaise qui semble une solution face à
la manière trop rigide de règne de
charles 10 et face au pouvoir plus
républicain qui rentre aussi en jeu à
cette époque
c'est la révolution de juillet 1830 qui
lui en offre l'occasion une violente
insurrection populaire oblige alors les
bourbon a quitté définitivement la
france
le pouvoir est en vacances leurs cousins
populiste louis philippe est placé sur
le trône
louis philippe né au sein de la maison
d'orléans le 6 octobre 17 173
il est le fils aîné de louis philippe
joseph duc de chartres connu sous le nom
de philippe égalité et de sa femme
louise marie adélaïde de bourbon
descendant en ligne directe du plus
jeune frère de louis xiv la maison
d'orléans et la branche cadette de la
famille des bourbons en 1785 le père de
louis philippe en succédant à son propre
père était devenu le chef de la maison
d'orléans il avait hérité le titre de
duc d'orléans et de premier prince du
sang ce qui faisait de lui le personnage
le plus important du royaume après la
famille du roi louis saez
par là même il était le premier dans
l'ordre de succession au trône
si la ligne est central des bourbons
venait à s'éteindre
c'est de son père que louis-philippe
reçoit le titre de duc de chartres et à
12 ans il devient l'héritier de la plus
grande fortune de france
le prince est né et a grandi au palais
royal
considérée comme la résidence principale
de la maison d'orléans depuis l'époque
de louis xiv
tout comme ses deux soeurs jumelles et
ses deux frères
il reçoit une éducation libérale leur
gouvernante la comtesse de genlis
instruit les cinq enfants dans un
bâtiment que le duc d'orléans leur père
a construit spécialement pour eux
ses méthodes d'enseignement non
traditionnels s'appuie sur les idées du
philosophe jean jacques rousseau sont
traitées très controversée et 1000 ou de
l'éducation explique comment élever et
éduquer un citoyen idéal
madame de genlis met l'accent sur les
langues vivantes l'activité physique et
les talents manuels la maison d'orléans
est connu pour ses idées libérales
depuis le début des années 1780
adepte des penseurs des lumières tels
que rousseau montesquieu le duc
d'orléans père de louis philippe rejeter
ouvertement le système politique de son
pays
il disait admirer un gouvernement dans
lequel l'autorité politique provient de
la volonté du peuple en raison de son
pouvoir social économique et politique
il réussit à créer au palais royal un
centre et un point de ralliement aux
ennemis de la cour qui jouera un rôle
important dans l'affaiblissement de la
couronne leduc se rendit également très
populaire en se montrant généreux envers
les pauvres durant les périodes de
famine
il ouvrit les jardins du palais royal au
public et autorise à l'installation de
boutiques sous les arcades
lorsque la révolution éclate en 1789 la
famille d'orléans embrasse sa cause avec
enthousiasme le duc est élu à la
convention nationale sous le nom de
philippe égalité mais n'aura jamais la
confiance pleine et entière des
révolutionnaires
certains le soupçonnaient de vouloir
utiliser le soulèvement pour assouvir
ses ambitions dynastiques en tant que
membre de la famille royale
louis philippe et déjà colonel de son
propre régime ans à l'âge de 12 ans il
se révèle un excellent soldats et ça
gêne ambition est favorisée par les
circonstances
au moment où la guerre éclate temps
d'officiers ont immigré qu'il devient le
colonel le plus gradé de l'armée
française comme son célèbre contemporain
napoléon bonaparte
il est très vite promu le jeune prince
devient également membre du club des
jacobins
avant de rejoindre son régiment en 1780
durant la révolution
[Musique]
louis fille va faire partie du club des
jacobins donc il va on va dire avoir
déjà un rôle
malgré son âge il y là il a 19 ans il
n'est pas n'est pas très vieux il va
avoir un petit rôle politique et c'est
surtout à partir du moment qui va
s'engager dans les armées du nord sous
la direction de dumouriez qu'il va
vraiment avoir un poids militaire parce
qu'il est vraiment partie prenante dans
les deux grandes batailles de vanier
jemmapes
et aussi ce prince qui s'engage auprès
de la révolution forcément le symbole le
symbole est très fort
la france est en guerre avec l'autriche
louis-philippe se bat avec un grand
courage
sur le front des flandres à la bataille
de jemmapes à la tête de l'armée du
centre il enfonça une position fermement
tenus par les autrichiens et jouer un
rôle décisif dans cette victoire qui
ouvrit les portes de la belgique aux
forces françaises
louis philippe est un homme très
intelligent d'humeur égale un beau jeune
homme au nez aquilin aux yeux bruns et
aux cheveux châtains à 19 ans il est à
la fois un prince de sang et un général
républicain respecté plus tard il
considérera cette période comme la plus
belle époque de sa vie mais cela ne dure
pas les factions s'affrontent à paris et
entraîne le reversement des modérés en
un rien de temps tout change
les radicaux prennent le contrôle
abolissent la monarchie et incarcère la
famille royale
horrifiée louis-philippe voit son père
philippe égalité voté pour l'exécution
de louis saez pour se concilier les
faveurs de l'ailé gauche des
révolutionnaires la france entre dans la
période que l'on appelle la terreur
louis philippe et dans l'armée du nord
sous le commandement du général charles
lefrançois dumouriez lorsqu'il comprend
qu'il ne peut plus soutenir la
révolution
très vite il est impliqué dans un
complot visant à renverser les
extrémistes et à restaurer la monarchie
constitutionnelle de 1790 dumouriez
projette de s'allier aux autrichiens et
marche sur paris mais le complot échoue
et du mouriez ainsi que louis-philippe
sont obligés de fuir et de se réfugier
dans le camp autrichien pour sauver leur
vie
le jeune prince dont l'avenir semblait
si prometteur ne faudra plus le seul
français pendant 20 ans louis-philippe
va errer à droite et à gauche en europe
en suisse par exemple où il va devoir
même jouer le rôle de professeur ou il
va aussi il tombe est secrètement
amoureux il ira même jusque dans le
grand nord puisque il sera fier de dire
je suis le premier français à être allés
jusqu'au grand nord il fera aussi des
enfants illégitimes la balle fille d'un
pasteur et puis quand il apprend que la
révolution va libérer ses frères qui
étaient emprisonnés à marseille
il décide de s'en aller beaucoup plus
loin c'est à dire aux états unis il va
rester pendant quelques temps aux états
unis avec ses frères ils vont arpenter
le nouveau monde cuba ils vont séjourner
à cuba et ensuite direction l'angleterre
où il attendra que ça se passe
louis-philippe étant déclarés ennemis de
la révolution
les membres de la famille d'orléans sont
arrêtés la défection du fils scelle le
destin du père philippe égalité et
compromis est condamné à monter sur
l'échafaud son fils en éprouvera une
culpabilité qui le poursuivra sa vie
durant
louis-philippe regrettera éternellement
de s'être lié aux jacobins et formera le
voeu de ne plus jamais accordé sa
confiance à qui que ce soit dans un
premier temps on va dire l'événement
marque ans avec son séjour en suisse ou
sous une fausse identité a enseigné la
géographie puis en passant par
l'allemagne il va remonter vers la
scandinavie où il va être un des
premiers à un des premiers français à
atteindre
on va dire vraiment les côtes
septentrionales de la norvège par la
suite après ce après ce périple il va se
rendre aux états unis avec ses frères où
il va faire un grand périple qui va
notamment le mener jusqu'aux chutes du
niagara
de retour de retour en europe il va
passer par l'angleterre puis quand même
cette période d'exil va être
particulièrement fructueuse pour lui
puisqu'il va quand même trouvé son
épouse pendant cette période dans le
royaume des deux siciles où il va se
marier en 1809
après son exil prend fin en 1814
avec le retour sur le trône de louis
xviii il va errer à travers l'europe et
le nouveau monde pendant près de 20 ans
fils de régicide il doit affronter
l'hostilité des monarchies européennes
il rejoint en exil sa soeur adélaïde qui
a réussi à s'échapper avec leur tutrice
madame de genlis
mais pour des raisons de sécurité il est
obligé de se séparer d'elle et de
voyager incognito il enseigne même un
temps la géographie dans un pensionnat
suisse avant de partir pour les
etats-unis où il va passer de nombreuses
années en 1800 en france napoléon
bonaparte renverse le gouvernement
révolutionnaire devenu impopulaire et
permet à louis-philippe de revenir en
europe avec ses deux jeunes frères
il s'installe en angleterre avec
adélaïde
mais les deux garçons moeurs bientôt de
la tuberculose qu'ils avaient contracté
dans les cachots de paris durant le
règne de la terreur une rencontre à
londres entre louis philippe et son
cousin charles d'artois frère cadet de
louis saez aboutir à une réconciliation
avec la branche aînée de la famille à
l'étranger
louis philippe a épousé sa cousine
espagnole marie-amélie fille de
ferdinand iv de naples et nièce de
marie-antoinette louis-philippe sa femme
et sa soeur restée célibataire
s'installe alors en sicile et même ce
que beaucoup décrivent comme un mariage
à trois
après la chute de napoléon en 1814 les
alliés européens replace les bourbons
sur le trône de france
le frère cadet de louis saez louis
stanislas comtes de provence devient
louis xviii
à la condition qu'il accepte la
monarchie constitutionnelle
bien que la charte constitutionnelle de
louis xviii donne beaucoup plus de
pouvoir au roi ray le droit de vote à un
nombre bien moindre de français que ne
le faisait la constitution républicaine
de 1791
elle permet de réconcilier la monarchie
et la révolution est d'apporter la paix
en europe après deux décennies d'exil
louis-philippe revient en france en
compagnie de sa famille il a déjà 40 ans
pour l'époque
c'est un vieillard mais le peuple n'a
pas oublié les exploits militaires de sa
jeunesse lorsqu'il était dans l'armée
révolutionnaire
après la restauration de la monarchie
il lui assure une popularité précieuse
il est le seul prince de france
survivants à n'avoir jamais rejeter la
révolution mais au contraire à s'être
battu pour elle cette réputation va
forger son avenir le flip après l'
empire est de retour il va négocier avec
louis xviii une grande part de ce qu'on
appelle le milliard des émigrés c'est à
dire que le u18 redonne partie de
l'argent qu'ils avaient été pillés aux
émigrés pendant la révolution et il est
suffisamment habile pour en récupérer à
peu près 75 % parce que c'est un les
ongles à gratter les fonds de tiroir un
louis philippe et il va retrouver tous
ses biens c'est à dire qu'il va devenir
le prince quasiment le plus riche
d'europe pourquoi parce que sa mère la
fille du duc de penthièvre louise marie
adélaïde de bourbon un tiers a hérité ne
sont pas pas une fortune considérable
pourquoi parce que son papa était le
seul métier de tous les bâtards de louis
xiv
donc ils sont à la tête d'une tribu de
château le château de annette arme un
vivier en bois etc
il a des châteaux et des domaines
partout sourit philippe et richissime il
va lui comme ses ancêtres s'installer à
paris au palais royal au palais royal où
il se fait discret pendant la
restauration de
de louis xviii et peut-être mutile un
peu sous charles 10 parce qu'il n'est
pas trop partisan de cette monarchie
ultra royalistes qu'impose le roi
charles d'istres enfin se manifeste pas
il reste dans l'ombre à son grand
soulagement
louis xviii lui rend tous les domaines
qui ont été confisqués à sa famille et
n'ont pas été vendus il devient très
riche mais les relations demeurent
difficiles entre les deux branches de la
famille royale
si le roi ne remet pas en question la
fidélité de louis philippe en revanche
il se méfie de sa popularité
ce qui le conduit à limiter les
apparitions publiques de son cousin la
famille d'orléans de manière générale
est ostensiblement tenu à l'écart du
cercle royal la fertilité de la branche
d'orléans est une autre raison pour
laquelle le roi n'apprécie pas le
premier prince du sang pendant que louis
xviii n'a pas d'enfant louis philippe
est béni par la naissance de cinq fils
et trois filles
le retour au pouvoir de napoléon épisode
connu sous le nom de 100 jours entraîne
louis xviii à fuir de nouveau et
louis-philippe à se retirer en exil en
angleterre la défaite finale de waterloo
permet le retour du roi au pouvoir mais
sa réputation est à jamais ternie si la
restauration des bourbons revêtent une
si grande importance si parce qu'elle
marque l'avènement en france d'un
gouvernement parlementaire moderne qui
va durer assez longtemps pour
s'enraciner dans le pays
son autorité la passivité du parlement
et sa décision pragmatique d'opter pour
une politique centriste vont permettre à
louis xviii de conserver le pouvoir
pendant 15 ans exclu de la vie politique
louis philippe haas la plupart de son
temps auprès de sa famille
après des années de difficultés
financières ils apprécient le confort de
sa nouvelle vie
il passe l'hiver au palais royal et
l'été au château de neuilly et de temps
en temps il se rend dans le berceau d
orléans a eu près de dieppe le duc
d'orléans cultive sa popularité en
faisant du palais royal le foyer des
libéraux en s'habillant bourgeois c'est
à dire en portant un pantalon long et
non une culotte et en envoyant ses fils
à l'école publique
en outre il irrite le roi en se
promenant dans les quartiers ouvriers de
paris et en s'y arrêtant pour discuter
avec la population
les problèmes commencent pour les
bourbons au moment de la seconde
restauration
quand louis xviii meurt et que son frère
charles 10 un conservateur monte sur le
trône
les partis politiques sont de plus en
plus en conflit charles c'est qu'il lui
est impossible de restaurer la monarchie
absolue mais il tente avec le parti
ultra de restaurer le pouvoir social et
économique du clergé et de la noblesse
ainsi que l'autorité morale de l'église
mais une majorité libérale se dégagent
les élections de 1830 et charles 10 se
sent menacé il tente obstinément de
garder son ministère qui a perdu tout
soutien comme louis xviii l'avait prédit
la nostalgie de charles pour l'ancien
régime
le conduite à vouloir abandonner la
constitution et affirmer son autorité
royale convaincu que la monarchie est en
danger le roi prend les mesures
d'urgence prévues par l'article 14 de la
charte
ce sont les quatre ordonnances de saint
cloud il supprime la liberté de la
presse
il change la loi électorale et il
dissout la chambre qui vient d'être élu
mais qui ne lui est pas favorable
c'est la population de paris
principalement d'abord dans les écoles
l'école polytechnique les populations
d'artisans des faubourgs qui se révolte
qui porte la révolution qui vont rendre
finalement renversé charles disent très
rapidement en quelques jours charles 10
comprend que tout est perdu
il s'éloigne à saint cloud à rambouillet
et finalement très vite et de prendre le
chemin de l'exil
les quatre ordonnance signée le 25
juillet bien qu'étrangement légal
constitue une attaque directe contre
l'esprit de la charte constitutionnelle
charles le but éviter de reproduire les
erreurs de son frère aîné louis saez
selon lui c'est son penchant pour les
libéraux au sein même de son
gouvernement qui lui a fait perdre son
trône
puis la vie lors de la révolution de
1789 mais celle-ci avait commencé en
réaction à ce qui avait été perçu comme
un coup d'état du roi et de ses
ministres
quarante ans plus tard charles s'apprête
à répéter les erreurs du passé
les ordonnances du roi perturbe le
délicat équilibre qui s'était installé
en france depuis 15 ans les sentiments
anti aristocratique se réveille en
quelques jours
paris est à nouveau en proie au
soulèvement
l'opposition au bourbon a toujours été
constituées de différents groupes aux
positions diverses charles leur offre
une raison de s'unir pour fomenter un
coup d'état
les libéraux se battent dans l'espoir de
former une nouvelle république
démocratique
les impérialistes cherche à se venger de
l'humiliation de la défaite
napoléonienne et les modérés
constitutionnaliste se bat simplement
pour défendre la loi et la constitution
contre les attaques de l'autorité royale
non seulement le roi a complètement
sous-estimé la réaction qui allait
susciter sa prise de pouvoir
mais les mesures militaires qu'il prend
pour affronter la résistance populaire
sont très insuffisantes
il est chassé de paris après trois jours
d'émeutes sanglantes
c'est ce qu'on appelle les trois
glorieuses où la révolution de juillet
le roi est en fuite la france a besoin
d'un nouveau gouvernement
doit-elle revenir à une république
dirigée par le peuple comme cela s'était
produit à la suite de la prise de la
bastille ou doit-elle revenir à l'
empire comme l'espèrent les anciens
bonapartiste une troisième voie serait
de se doter d'un roi qui rétablirait la
monarchie constitutionnelle que charles
a osé mettre en péril les politiciens
les plus importants de la chambre des
députés craignant un retour aux excès de
la première république volts instaurer
un gouvernement provisoire afin que
d'autres factions ne rassemblent leurs
forces représentants de la bourgeoisie
aisée
ils sont favorables à un retour du statu
quo on a toujours vu la famille
d'orléans
d'une faction politique à part entière
s'était déjà le vrai avec son père et ça
va être vrai avec le fils est à dire que
le fils par rapport à louis xviii et à
charles 10 va représenter toujours la
famille royale mais une famille royale
plus libérale donc son ascension sociale
c'est d'abord une ascension qui va se
faire notamment par les grandes fêtes
qu'il va donner au palais royal où va se
réunir toute la frange libérale des du
personnel politique de l'époque et cette
ascension elle est un petit peu
symbolisée par une phrase de louis 18
qui disait comment voulez vous arrêter
quelqu'un qui ne semble pas avancer et
c'est exactement ce que va faire
louis philippe il va toujours être dans
cet entre-deux il va avoir cette
intelligence politique de ne jamais se
poser franchement à ses cousins mais
tout en se créant une clientèle qui va
lui servir beaucoup quand il va monter
sur le trône à cette époque le terme d'
orléaniste se rattache au mouvement
favorable à une monarchie
constitutionnelle
plutôt que de laisser le pouvoir aux
mains du peuple
les députés proposent d'instaurer une
monarchie orléaniste avec louis philippe
à sa tête
si l'on veut sauver la monarchie
il n'y a pas une minute à perdre les
libéraux qui ont courageusement combattu
dans les rues de paris existe une
nouvelle république qui établirait le
suffrage universel
beaucoup d'entre eux sont trop jeunes
pour se souvenir des carnages des champs
de bataille et de la guillotine leur
chef est un héros de la première
révolution le général lafayette sont
même avoir son accord
la chambre des députés se rallier à
louis philippe celui ci a gardé le
silence durant ces jours de violence
pour ne pas qu'on l'accuse de vouloir
usurper le pouvoir de son cousin
il a même quitté son domicile de neuilly
pour se cacher dans un endroit secret
mais adélaïde sa soeur sert
d'intermédiaire
on ignore souvent mais elle a joué un
rôle décisif dans l'accession de son
frère au pouvoir qu'elle ait réagi avec
ou sans son consentement
ce qui est certain c'est qu'en son
absence c'est elle qui a courageusement
accepté au nom de son frère
la proposition d'accéder au trône cette
promesse conclu c'est au tour de louis
philippe d'agir il doit effacé
l'obstacle qui reste sur le chemin du
pouvoir
il quitte le palais royal sur un cheval
blanc et traverse les foules inconstante
qui emplissent les rues
bien qu'ils risquent à tout moment
d'être assassiné par un opposant il se
dirige courageusement à la tête d'un
cortège vers le centre traditionnel du
pari révolutionnaire l'hôtel de ville
la fayette est là et la population a
cours en masse pour montrer son soutien
à la république
les deux hommes apparaissent ensemble
aux balcons de l'édifice lafayette qui
n'a pas assez confiance pour prétendre à
la fonction suprême donne soudain
l'accolade à louis philippe et lui tend
un drapeau tricolore que les deux hommes
brandissent très haut
à cet instant les chance d'instaurer une
nouvelle république sont balayées c'est
la monarchie constitutionnelle qu'ils
l'emportent
on rappelle aux républicains que le duc
d'orléans dans sa jeunesse a vaillamment
combattu pour la révolution et la
promesse que la monarchie
constitutionnelle va s'appuyer sur les
idéaux républicains emportent leur
soutien c'est une monarchie on appelle
constitutionnel c'est-à-dire basé sur un
texte qu'on appelle la charte
or la charte elle existait déjà sous
louis xviii
mais elles étaient octroyés c'est à dire
c'était le roi qui donnait un certain
nombre de droits à son peuple
là on va dire que le la différence est
dans la rédaction de l'achat puisque la
charte c'est on va dire plus un contrat
entre le peuple et le roi et c'est pour
ça que louis-philippe n'est plus roi de
france mais roi des français
le 7 août 2008 130 louis philippe duc
d'orléans alors âgé de 57 ans est
proclamé roi des français
cet acte rompt avec la tradition
héréditaire et redéfinit le concept de
royautés le roi de france devient roi
des français car ils ne montrent plus
sur le trône par la volonté divine mais
par celle de la nation
oui philippe a attendu beaucoup de
monter sur le trône il a été l'homme
qu'on a imaginé un moment pour prendre
le pouvoir à la sous le directoire sous
le consulat à la fin de l' empire
pendant la restauration
il a attendu ce trône pendant presque
quarante ans il se considère comme un
bourbon il est d'abord il est il et
bourbon et prince jusqu'au bout des
ongles on peut le dire il est très
conscient de aussi de son destin
probablement son destin historique
politique et il entend est monté sur le
trône mais il veut il a surtout le souci
en fait de réconcilier les français avec
eux même réconcilier les bonapartistes
les légitimistes les monarchistes de
tous poils en fait
ehret avec légalement la république qui
est quand même aussi dont les idées sont
un acquis de la révolution
il est un fils de la révolution il veut
il se présente comme le garant des
acquis de la révolution
l'élu roi citoyen louis-philippe malgré
son âge avancé assume son rôle avec brio
il arbore autant qu'il le peut le
drapeau tricolore et règne sans
prétention en évitant les fastes et les
dépenses somptuaires de ses
prédécesseurs surtout il rétablit après
révision la charte de 1814 ce qui permet
au nombre d'électeurs de doubler alors
ce sont les chambres qui ont beaucoup de
pouvoir et dieu merci parce que
louis-philippe veut gouverner au centre
et c'est pas facile de gouverner au
centre
quand on a un pays qui est divisé en
trois grands pôles on a les
bonapartistes qui sont très puissants on
a les républicains qui sont là qui
deviennent de plus en plus puissants et
on a les légitimistes c'est à dire les
partisans des bourbons alors il est
obligé de de concilier toutes ces trois
parties et de faire parfois le grand
écart pour parvenir à gouverner
il ya un parlement qui est plus fort du
moins une assemblée de députés qui est
plus forte
c'est en cela que c'est une monarchie
constitutionnelle et en fait le jeu va
être entre les ministres le roi et
l'assemblée des l'assemblée des députés
et c'est cet équilibre qui va jouer
pendant 18 ans soit en faveur du roi
soit en faveur
chef du gouvernement en fait les
équilibres ont changé au fur et à mesure
des personnalités qui vont être en jeu
pendant ses 18 ans au début il est très
aimée mais sa popularité commencent à
souffrir quand il devient clair que la
révolution qui a mis fin au règne des
bourbon n'a pas permis de modifier
radicalement la structure de la société
et des instances politiques le
gouvernement de la france se rapproche
de celui d'une monarchie parlementaire
mais il ya encore du chemin à faire
la presse ne tarde pas à affirmer que la
révolution de 1830 a été confisqué et le
respect de la constitution et de la loi
on remplaçait celui qui était dévolu à
dieu et à l'huile sainte de clovis
emblème de la souveraineté sans cette
légitimité de droit divin
louis philippe est plus vulnérable aux
attaques la monarchie de juillet doit
faire face sur deux fronts celui des
libéraux qui veulent restaurer la
république et celui des légitimistes qui
veulent rétablir les bourbons adélaïde
devient la confidente la plus proche du
roi elle est brillante ambitieuse est
entièrement dévoué à son frère elle a
pesé de toute son influence pour que
celui ci accède au trône et continuera à
lui prodiguer ses conseils éclairés
tout au long de son règne ils divergent
sur un seul point
quelle faction constitue la menace la
plus sérieuse contre louis philippe
celui ci est convaincue qu'elle vient de
l'extrême droite qui a soutenu charles
disent leurs idées politiques sont sans
doute le reflet de leur expérience
personnelle de la première révolution
tous deux ont dû à cette époque quitter
leur pays
ils ont perdu leur toit et leur père
bien aimé mais louis philippe a pu voir
les atrocités commises pendant la
période de la première république
il a grandi dans la crainte des
soulèvements populaires et dans la
conviction que l'autorité monarchique
doit remplir une fonction d' équilibre
adélaïde elle est trop jeune pour se
souvenir du chaos qui régnait en 1793
elle est surtout marquée par ses années
d'exil
elle n'oubliera jamais le traitement
cruel réservé à sa famille en tant
qu'immigré royalistes le roi est
critiqué par les libéraux comme par les
nationalistes qui fustigent sa faiblesse
sur le plan militaire il répond qu'il
n'hésiterait pas à défendre la france en
cas de nécessité
mais qu'il préfère l'avoir libre que
grande il confie à son fils qu'il a pu
s'apercevoir au cours de sa vie que la
gloire n'apportait que la destruction
comme c'est un vrai en politique
au fur et à mesure et va quand même
essayer de jouer un véritable rôle
politique et c'est justement dans ce
dans ce jeu entre les différentes
personnes qui vont être placés au
ministère qu'il va pouvoir naviguer
suivant les caractères et des uns et des
autres les efforts diplomatiques non
interventionniste de son gouvernement et
sa politique étrangère permettent à la
france de jouir de la prospérité que
procure la paix grâce à l'engagement
officieux d'adélaïde dans les affaires
étrangères les relations entre la france
et l'angleterre resteront au beau fixe
durant tout son règne sur l'invitation
de louis philippe la reine victoria se
rendra à eux à deux reprises la première
fois pour conclure une ébauche d'entente
cordiale
c'est la première fois que des monarques
des deux pays se rencontrent depuis
l'entrevue du drap d'or en 15 120 entre
henri 8 d'angleterre et françois 1er
l'entente cordiale c'est la venue au
château 2 de la reine victoria
les conflits étaient nombreux à cette
époque entre l'angleterre et la france
et
la reine victoria qui vient plus où
dans une aspects de visites familiales
en fait va venir avec ses ministres
qu'ils vont vraiment faire le travail
diplomatique a eu par deux fois en 1843
en 1845 pour rendre visite à la famille
royale française au louis philippe
pétain un roi qui a été pétri par par
l'angleterre si je puis dire d'abord
parce que ce son père philippe égalité
de l'île d'orléans était un anglophile
c'est lui qui a introduit les courses de
chevaux en france par exemple et louis
philippe a passé une grande partie de
son exil pendant la révolution sur le
sol anglais
il aimait l'angleterre et il s'est dit
en arrivant au pouvoir en 1830
il faudrait quand même que nous essayons
d'oublier les griefs qu'il ya pu avoir
entre la france et l'angleterre à cause
de napoléon 1er et il va inviter la
toute nouvelle petite reine victoria qui
vient de monter sur le trône
d'angleterre qui va venir en france au
château 2 en 1843 elle va venir passer
huit jours au château 2 et elle va être
sous le charme de ce papy qui était
louis philippe car c'est véritablement
un petit papy adorable avec elle qui est
encore une gamine de 18 ans il a promène
par exemple dans le verger et une vidéo
vous avez vu comme cette baisse est
pêché est belle et il lui offre
shocking cela dit la petite victoria
qu'est ce que je vais faire d'une pêche
elle n'est pas habituée généralement lui
donne une petite assiette en or avec un
petit couteau en or une serviette en
dentelle alors louis-philippe sort de sa
poche un gros couteau peine la pêche et
l'offre à victoria elle y voyez-vous
dans la vie j'ai souvent dans kent ou et
je ne sépare jamais de mon couteau
depuis il ne faut cependant pas
longtemps avant que le gouvernement de
louis philippe soit perçu comme trop
conservateur il musèle la presse et
refuse d'élargir l'électorat
les tensions atteignent leur apogée en
les funérailles nationales d'un député
nationaliste provoque un soulèvement
républicains au cri de la liberté ou la
mort
la population dresse rapidement des
barricades comme sous henri iv et
s'oppose aux troupes gouvernementales
envoyé pour contrer l'insurrection
les deux jours de guerre civile qui se
déroule dans les quartiers populaires du
centre et de l'est parisien sont
rapidement contenu ils seront plus tard
immortalisé dans le roman célèbre de
victor hugo les misérables
louis-philippe d'abord quand il était
lui n'est plus mais plutôt de jeunesse
c'est un brave homme je crois que il
il cherche toujours à être conciliant
parfois un peu trop parce qu'ils se
laissent souvent influencé mais il veut
essayer de faire plaisir à tout le monde
la preuve les bonhommes les
bonapartistes par exemple qui sont un
petit peu ses ennemis bon pour leur
faire plaisir que fait-il
à peine devenu louis-philippe raleigh
français il fait revenir le descendre
les restes de napoléon 1er aux invalides
ça ça fait plaisir et ainsi de suite il
est toujours celle toujours d'être
conciliant mais c'est peine perdue parce
que les républicains vont sans arrêt lui
mettre des bâtons dans les roues avec
eux il va essuyer plus de 10 aux deux
attentats
la mise en question de sa légitimité
combiné à l'instabilité politique rend
louis-philippe plus vulnérables aux
agressions physiques que ses
prédécesseurs il survit aux 80 hâtive
d'assassinât perpétrée contre lui un
nombre sans précédent
l'étroitesse d'esprit persiste à
l'intérieur même du gouvernement
mais l'attentât particulièrement
sanglant qui touche le roi en 1835
fomenté par un certain giuseppe fier qui
est suivi par dix ans de paix de
prospérité et de stabilité politique
étrangement il suscite un effet inverse
que celui escompté et rallie le peuple à
s'en voit en 1837 la monarchie profite
du mariage du fils aîné du duc d'orléans
fils du roi pour lancer une campagne de
réconciliation nationale
c'est une immense réussite qui marque
l'apogée du règne de louis philippe
leroy en concession allèles gauche de la
nation accorde l'amnistié aux
prisonniers et donne des fonds pour la
reconstruction de l'église de saint
germain l'auxerrois afin de faire la
paix avec la droite
c'est à cette époque également que
louis-philippe s'engage dans la
transformation du palais de versailles
alors abandonné en un musée national et
qu'il sauve ainsi l'édifice le plus
important de l'ancien régime pour
montrer son implication dans ce projet
ils financent sur ses propres deniers
la restauration de versailles il a des
adversaires de tous les côtés loin
philippe il veut gouverner au centre
mais il est cerné étendant son centre il
est cerné on le sait par les futurs
socialistes qui sont là déjà assez bien
installé par évidemment les
bonapartistes qui sont des nostalgiques
et par les purs et durs les ultras
royalistes non tous ces gens là
cherchent à lui nuire
mais les interminables querelles entre
le centre gauche et le centre-droit
affaiblissent le régime aux yeux de la
population
bientôt le mouvement républicain ne peut
plus être ignoré et le régime en place a
du mal à défendre le statu quo
une campagne est lancée destinée à faire
le lien entre ce régime et les jours
glorieux de l' empire
la france demande à la grande-bretagne
d'autoriser le retour des cendres de
napoléon bonaparte la foule s'étend le
long des rues pour voir passer le
cercueil de l'empereur depuis la scène
jusqu'aux champs-elysées avant qu'il
repose en paix aux invalides
ce geste symbolique produit l'effet
escompté
le peuple est envahi par la fierté
nationale mais l'euro en tire
certainement aussi une grande
satisfaction sur le plan personnel
durant 16 ans il n'avait été qu'un
réfugié tandis que napoléon diriger la
france
et maintenant napoléon était mort en
exil et lui roi des français enterrait
son rival
louis-philippe s'appuie sur les arts
pour façonner l'opinion
ils commandent plus de tableau que tout
autre gouvernement du 19e siècle les
portraits royaux s'éloigne de la
tradition renforçant ainsi son image de
roi citoyen déjà sous napoléon l'art
avait été utilisée comme une forme de
propagande
le choix de sujets réaliste rompt avec
le romantisme de l'époque et pose les
fondations du réalisme français du 19e
siècle
l'hommage au grand général d'austerlitz
entraîne une brève flambé de
bonapartisme qui alimentent les espoirs
du neveu de napoléon le prince louis
napoléon le fils unique de l'empereur
s'étant éteint en 1832
dans le climat qui règne en france louis
napoléon pense naïvement qu'il pourrait
réussir un coup d'état mais la monarchie
de juillet est assez stable pour que son
entreprise soit stoppée avant même
d'avoir été mis en oeuvre malgré toute
la bonne volonté déployée en 1840 la
monarchie de juillet est en complet
décalage avec le peuple
[Musique]
le ministère a connu des changements
incessants et le conservatisme croissant
du roi se reflète dans le nouveau
remaniement de 1840
c'est à ce moment quand même que
soulèvent les mouvements républicains
véritable juillet où des gens comme
blanqui notamment vont se révéler alors
il ya blanqui qui le symbole un petit
peu plus fort de ces mouvements
républicains les légitimistes qui n'ont
jamais à avaler le fait que
louis-philippe récupère comme on disait
dans le ruisseau la couronne qui
normalement est échu à charlo 10 et
charles disent quand ils abdiquent
normalement abdique en faveur de son
petit fils donc vos philippe ne devait
être qu'un
qu un régent donc les légitimistes ont
eu du mal à avaler à aller ça et on voit
aussi émerger la personnalité du futur
napoléon iii qui par deux fois va
essayer de soulever des troupes et ce
qui finalement va le
ce qui va lui arriver ce qui va se
retrouver à la forteresse de hamm don
qui se libérera au bout de quelques
quelques années mais on voit vraiment
que louis-philippe doit faire face à
beaucoup de mouvements politiques
différents le ministre des affaires
étrangères françois guizot recours à la
corruption pour vaincre l'opposition qui
monte au sein de la chambre pour la
première fois le parlement est unifié
c'est un homme sérieux c'est un
protestant traits un peu austère qui va
essayer de gêner dans de ménager la
chèvre et le chou il va essayer de
concilier toutes les tendances
politiques de ménager la france par
rapport à l'étranger
efa les relations franco anglaise en
particulier en essayant de prôner
l'entente cordiale mais son régime qui
va être appelé le régime du juste milieu
c'est à dire celui qui ne prend parti ni
d'un côté ni de l'autre ne l'emportera
pas et très vite il s'enfermera un peu
dans un immobilisme qui va entraîner la
chute du régime en février 1848
mais le fils aîné du roi ferdinand
philippe décède subitement dans un
accident de calèche
ce prince charmant et intelligent était
conscient du danger d'un système
électoral très peu représentatif de la
nation
en tant qu'héritier du trône il
représentait pour beaucoup l'espoir d'un
avenir meilleur pour tous les français
et pour l'humanité en général
sa disparition est une catastrophe leroy
terrassé par cette perte douloureuse ne
sera plus jamais tout à fait le même
en 1847 louis philippe a non seulement
perdu tout pouvoir sur le climat qui
règne dans le pays mais il est devenu
incapable de changement confronté à
d'importantes transformations sociales
économiques et démographiques
louis philippe et son ministère refuse
tout compromis sur la réforme électorale
avec un parlement conservateurs qui est
opposé leroy justifie sa position en
arguant qu'elle serait
inconstitutionnelle mais c'est là que
réside le problème
comment un électorat aussi réduit
peut-il représenter le peuple les
conditions de vie de la classe ouvrière
se détériore et l'écart entre les
revenus se creuse de plus en plus le
mécontentement de la population renforce
les dirigeants du mouvement républicain
le peuple est prêt à prendre la parole
cela fait après tout 60 ans qu'il s'est
proclamé libre pour la première fois à
la prison de la bastille et sur les
marches de l'hôtel de ville
mais le roi continue de penser que les
élites traditionnelles protège la nation
de l'anarchie et qu'il est plus
important de les ménager que d'accorder
davantage de liberté au peuple ils
ignorent les signaux d'alarmé et refuse
obstinément les réformes électorales
son attitude a pour résultat de
déclencher une autre révolution violente
et la chute de la monarchie
le 22 février 1848 paris se dresse
contre lui et le gouvernement perd le
contrôle de la situation après une série
d'erreurs militaires destinées à freiner
l'opposition pour éviter toute effusion
de sang
louis-philippe abdique
l'assemblée nationale projette de
transmettre le titre de roi des français
au petit fils de louis philippe
le comte de paris mais l'opinion
publique rejette cette idée de toutes
ses forces
les leaders républicains qui attendent
leurs moments depuis 1830 veille à ce
que la france ne connaissent plus jamais
de roy à sa tête le 26 février 1848 et
proclamé la seconde république
louis-philippe avait prévu de finir ses
jours dans sa propriété de e
mais lorsque lui parviennent les
nouvelles de paris il se souvient du
destin tragique de son cousin louis saez
et comprend que sa vie est en danger
cidre est en france pendant le l'hiver
de la fin de l'année 1847 le début de
l'hiver 2148 paris s'échauffent paris à
froid paris afin paris s'échauffer on
organise des banques et ce sont les
socialistes ou les républicains qui
organise des banques est autorisé par
louis-philippe d'ailleurs parce que il
est libéral
il autorise la liberté de la presse il
autorise ces banquets et puis ses
banquettes tourne mal parce que l'armée
va commencer à tirer
louis-philippe interdit que l'on tire
sur la foule il ne veut pas il ne veut
pas avoir de sens sur la conscience
alors qui le dira plus tard j'ai vu la
république tirer sur les parisiens eux
n'ont pas de conscience mais moi j'en
avais une et ses banques et vont
l'emporter si je puis dire et il va être
obligé de fuir de quitter paris en
catastrophe de traverser lui aussi comme
l'avait fait charles 10 en 1830 18
années plus tôt la normandie pour gagner
la côte
la côte normande et l'angleterre et se
réfugier en angleterre au château de
clermont où il mourra en 1850
en quelques heures la révolution de
février a contraint louis philippe a
abdiqué à renverser son gouvernement et
l'a obligé à fuir pour sauver sa vie le
gouvernement de la reine victoria est de
la famille d'orléans à fuir vers
l'angleterre
là elle est logée à clermont dans le sud
est où louis philippe meurs le 26 août
1850 il semble qu'après avoir survécu à
trois révolutions il était victime de
saturnisme une maladie contractée en
buvant de l'eau contaminée
s'ils restent et ceux de son épouse
seront rapatriés en france en 1876 est
inhumée dans la chapelle royale de dreux
nécropole familiale d orléans que sa
mère avait fait construire en 1816 et
qu'il avait agrandi et embelli après sa
mort si le fils du roi aux idées
progressistes n'était pas mort
prématurément la monarchie aurait-elle
pu continuer sa route le jeune prince
aurait peut être consenti à transformer
la monarchie constitutionnelle en une
véritable monarchie nationale
rapprochons ainsi la france d'un système
démocratique et la rendant du même coup
moins sujette aux accès révolutionnaire
les historiens se demandent également si
la série d'erreurs qui ont précipité
l'abdication du roi n'aurait pu être
évité si sa soeur adélaïde n'était pas
morte deux mois auparavant
elle s'était toujours montrée plus apte
que lui à prendre des décisions dans les
situations d'urgence
la révolution de 1848
même s'il constitue un moment important
de la monarchie française est un échec à
la fin de l'année les parisiens élise
louis napoléon bonaparte neveu du grand
napoléon bonaparte président de la
seconde république afin qu'il restaure
l'ordre et tout comme son oncle avant
lui il finit par s'emparer du pouvoir à
ses propres fins il se proclame
président à vie en 1851 puis en 1852 il
met un terme à la seconde république
pour se proclamer empereur du second
empire le règne de louis-philippe est
également considéré comme un échec mais
ne peut-on dire que ces réalisations ont
tout simplement été ignorés pour être
modeste comparée à celle du grand
napoléon ses réussites n'en sont pas
moins éclatante la monarchie de juillet
est l'un des gouvernements qui a duré le
plus longtemps
après la chute de la bastille elle a
étendu les libertés du peuple français
lui a procuré 18 ans de paix et de
relative prospérité
quand les événements se sont retournés
contre louis philippe devant la
perspective d'une guerre civile
il a préféré abdiqué pour éviter que son
peuple ne soit plongé dans un bain de
sang louis philippe a instauré la
monarchie constitutionnelle qui
convenait à la france il à apaiser les
tensions entre les pouvoirs exécutif et
législatif qui avait eu raison de louis
xviii et de charles 10 il a jeté les
bases d'un système parlementaire
celui ci fut abandonnée durant le second
empire mais refit surface sous la
direction des anciens orléaniste quand
la future troisième république choisi de
s'orienter vers une constitution
libérale ayant cette caractéristique
unique d'être à la fois de sang royal et
révolutionnaire louis-philippe monta sur
le trône avec une bonne volonté patente
mais en 1830 la révolution de juillet
donnant naissance à des attentes que le
gouvernement ne pu satisfaire
[Musique]
dans sa jeunesse louis-philippe avait
sans doute adhéré à l'idée d'un
gouvernement véritablement parlementaire
mais le roi de 78 ans choisi de garder
tout le pouvoir entre ses mains les
souvenirs violent et douloureux de son
passé
le en terre toute sa vie il lui furent
bien utile pour le guider avec sagesse
vers une politique de paix plutôt que
vers la recherche de la gloire mais il
l'empêchèrent en même temps de prévoir
l'avenir la monarchie pris fin parce que
louis-philippe ne voulut pas comprendre
les besoins d'une société en pleine
mutation
ironie de l'histoire le prince d'orléans
connu pour son libéralisme a finalement
été renversé à cause de son
conservatisme mais son règne contribuer
à l'évolution du système parlementaire
français